lukas jetzt soll ich heute gewonnen wird
eine komplette welt in die luft sprengen
hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einem weiteren
minecraft wo ich euch drei fix plus ein
fun fact vorstelle was ist so minecraft
vielleicht gibt was ihr eventuell noch
nicht kennt irgendwie immer jetzt so die
anfangs klassenhöheren ihr selbst und
schwarz - einfach in die kommentare und
rechtes ohr fragt in der nächsten folge
mieter bei euch gefällt würde ich mich
über einen daumen hoch freuen uns wenn
ihr mehr wollt zeigt mir dass auf und
ich witze angefangen direkt an mit dem
ersten effekt und zwar etwas mit ihm zu
tun hier alle freuen sich immer wenn ich
den trainer hand aber dann immer alles
schief geht da habe ich schon kleinen
test gemacht und zwar ist perfekt werden
der fact effektvoll der infekte volle
punkte also wenn ich dnt auf eis setzte
hier ja ich habe haben aber wenn ich das
anzünden explodieren lassen sich schon
die explosion die kenner unter euch
wissen dies größer als die als normal
tnt also hierzu der umkreis wenn ich
jetzt mal tnt zum beispiel hier hinten
mache das ist auf dem eis aber ich
kann's auch hier machen allerdings ist
das auf dem schneematsch zu sehen weil
beim schnee das immer gleich größe aus
täglich auf den schließlich die
explosion immer noch größer aus deswegen
ist das schlecht zu demonstrieren weil
auf dem schnee ist immer da wird immer
noch der schnee hier ein bisschen weg
gemacht deswegen sieht dass da immer ein
bisschen mehr aus explosion allerdings
ist das hier die explosion im schnee und
das beim wasser und ich denke man sieht
eigentlich so mit bloßem auge dass es
größer ist beim 1 und hier sieht man das
auch noch mal relativ klar rechts
da sieht man relativ deutlich weil hier
und da das sieht man schon dass das ich
einfach viel weiter nach außen geht also
hier ist die explosion größer also da
zwar nur geringfügig allerdings ist die
explosion wenn tnt auf eis steht größer
als wenn es auf normalen
steht es regnet teils verdammt da sollte
ich mal lieber ganz schnell nach hause
laufen ist wo ist mein zuhause acht da
ist mein zuhause park chance schnell
nach hause es regnet zum glück gibt es
dieses tolle features bekommen crafter
gezeigt dass ich mich einfach in meinem
bett legen kann auch wenn es tag ist und
es regnet und dann lege ich mich einfach
rein oder interessiert und dann kann ich
trotzdem schlafen dann wenn ich wieder
aufwache ist zwar immer noch tag aber es
hört dann auch zu regnen
also gezeigt hat war
wenn es regnet auch tagsüber könnt ihr
trotzdem hennen gehen und dann hört der
regen einfach auf das kennen bestimmt
schon einige von euch allerdings ist es
auch immer die gerichtet die das halt
nicht wissen
das sollte eigentlich eine hauswand
darstellen das es von vorne wie diesen
alten film sofort eine wand ist und das
haus nett und bleibt ihr wisst ich lebte
bei minecraft geithner ein bisschen mühe
fürs detail und jetzt ist wieder die
chance dass ich diesen ganzen nächsten
aufräumen soll az die einfach mal übels
viele vögel hingeschmissen mist hab ich
gar nicht angedacht dass lukas
zurückgewonnen wird seine komplette welt
in die luft sprengen will gar nicht
beginnen dürfen also wenn ihr einen tee
blog nimmt ich nehme mal wieder hier ein
aus
dann nehmt ihr noch ein amboss und dann
nehme ich etwas mit den tnt anzuzünden
das tnt und ihr stellt das tmt hin und
packten amboss obendrauf und zündet das
dann an dann wird das tnt das zittern
und geht ein stück zur seite als es wird
quasi und sich bei ihr könnt dann auch
dadurch hoffentlich inzwischen des tnt
könnt ihr einfach durchlaufen
weil das nicht mehr direkt auf dem blog
steht und nicht mehr an direkter
subvention eller blog ist ja einfach so
rum steht ihr könnt weil sie dadurch
laufen deswegen fällt der amboss in den
in das terrain
und während das team die eigentlich
explodiert teleportiert sich das dnt
nach oben über den amboss und dann kann
es keinen schaden erzeugen weil es dann
hier oben drauf ist und der amboss
blockiert irgendwie die komplette fläche
also zeigt ist das noch mal ganz kurz so
dass tnt verrückt ist durchsichtig quasi
teleportiert sich oben drauf und kann
keinen schaden erzeugen weil der amboss
dass ihr unternehmen wie alles blockiert
das war die dritte änderung bzw was
änderung dritte vorstellen wollte und
zwar einfach wenn tnt unter einem amboss
ist und jetzt sind das tnt dann fällt
die rambos quasi runter tnt teleportiert
sich hoch und es passiert gar nichts so
freunde der fun fact heute ist nicht
direkt von beats mit die eingereicht
worden allerdings von einem paar beenden
von denen und zwar meinten die zu mir
dass die manchmal einfach so ozelot ganz
viele so auf seinem blog pack und dann
einfach so rein schlag und dann passiert
was tolles und die fliegen alle
auseinander deswegen machen wir das
jetzt mal ganz kurz wörter ich dachte
das sei normal
achtet passiert aber st
ich dachte jetzt die werden ja davon
geschleudert wie alter ich weiß nicht ob
das war aber das was er wollte aber
alter alte alter alte alter alte alter
wo mein gott oh mein gott oh mein gott
walther alter alter alter das sind wir
viel zu viele rot zu laut zu malen das
ist die zu viele solchen mann
na ja heute ich so höre ich auch immer
auf euch alter falkenhain
wie soll ich das hinkriegen ja ich weiß
es gibt hier schaden sowohl tränke
irgendwie werk bereits dankend rang der
stärke stärke 3 soll also die reagieren
da einfach mal gar nicht drauf du mich
verarschen
die reagieren auf tränke die stärke
tränke ach das ist ja frank der stärkere
ist natürlich auch natürlich muss er das
hier nehmen sofortiger schaden ja aber
jetzt funktioniert alter okay ich habe
jetzt erst mal ein bisschen zu tun
freund das war's mit dem minecraft guide
paar hat sieben oder sechs ich weiß es
gar nicht so genau wo wir gerade sind
ich muss ja auch alle mehrmals treffen
[ __ ] ich habe so viel zu tun jetzt aber
danach bin ich ihm wieder wird 10.000
oder so ach man das war zwar kein
richtiger fand aber das haben sich viele
leute gewünschten kommentaren das ist
dafür mache deswegen kann das nummer
auch kommen so als fun fact
na gut freunde ich hoffe wenn es euch
gefallen hat und die weitere solche
totalen behinderten aktion von mir sehen
wollte was weitere weitere fun fact dann
gibt einfach einen daumen hoch und
schreibt mir eventuell weitere text in
die kommentare bisschen gleich am besten
gefallen hat
und vielleicht weiß auch ihnen jemand an
die 1.6 rauskommt weil ich dachte kommt
die wochenende aber ich kann jetzt nicht
also das könnte man die kommentare
schreiben mit dass man sich schnell
informieren und ich jetzt noch immer
zehn jahre weiter rum bis dieser alle
weg sind und dann sehen wir uns beim
nächsten mal wieder typisch